on May 1st 2012 film courage attended a
press roundtable interview with Ava
Mendez and Sierra Ramirez for the film
garland progress directed by Patricia
Regan this audio is from that interview
session for more information on girl in
progress please visit girl in progress
movie.com I can get I can get into that
you know and you know whether it be a
singing class or whether it be I just
took a bunch of I know but I've always
I've always I've always wanted to I
enjoy giving massages and like you know
my mother funny ways just uh my mom but
my mom always had lectures terrible neck
problems and back problems so I grew up
kind of like massaging her so I feel
like I you know she trained me well
there's something there so I
yeah I think I had a you know I think
the years I think between like seventh
grade and you know maybe my junior
senior year in high school were pretty
difficult because I was really try was
on a mission I wanted to be my own
independent person and I'm so close and
especially back then I was so close to
my family and so closely tied to them
and their beliefs that I really wanted
to divorce myself from them and figure
out who I was independent of them so
that was my mission and and that was
rocky what did you see in this some in
this role both when you read the script
what was it that really pulled you in
that's good when threw me into this
character was definitely the transition
that she goes through through from all
the way from good girl to bad girl she
goes through everything in between and I
thought that was really fun because you
don't come across many roles like that
and the fact that through all of it over
everything it was all just for the love
of the mother I think that was really
important is it didn't matter who she
hurt I was attracted to the fact that
you know the character was such a mess
of a woman's that the disaster of the
mother but really truly trying her best
so I wanted to play really you know
flawed real human being and
and I knew within the first few pages of
the script that she was so I you know
I'm a single mom myself thank God yeah
but I don't know it really struck a
chord for me because I feel sometimes I
was out trying my best to work and
survive and and you know so I cried like
almost drowned for you yeah so I'm
thinking that's gonna happen to some
audiences especially when it's like
really triggers but I go and about to
cry now it's very emotional I think it
really brings up emotions we also meet
grace a very likable character even
though she was you know really oh that's
cool because III you know III think
she's just awful yeah I do I mean I love
that she's you know a work in progress
and I love that she's trying her best
and she somehow finds her way but yeah I
just think wow it's hard for me to
divorce myself too though from the
character at this point and be objective
but because I still have to see her and
I'm just like stop smoking your kids
could she shun the gorgeous on any of
their beds Matthew Modine come on right
there that speaks to the caliber of
woman she's not just what's in the play
but about her plan about not just what's
in it but also how she goes about it in
that very organized way is that what
you're like I mean would you put that
that puts her up on the wall and had
that whole Babel playing her like in
that sentence that I would never think
about mapping out a whole coming-of-age
story
I couldn't just bring it down to a
couple oh I need to experience this all
in the experience back I just kind of
ride with the ride the waves growing up
and I'm not in any rush plan on pop
culture things that she's seen both of
you are in the pop culture and there's
that role model quality that comes with
that how do you feel how do you wear
that that mantle for for young girls
that want to look up to you and
sometimes model their behaviors career
but I don't know I don't think I feel
about that because I don't think I'm in
any position to teach some urge you know
guide someone to grow up because I'm
still learning myself and I don't think
anyone should the type of roles that you
take on are gonna reflect on people and
then they're their idea of you being a
role model and I think that you know any
role that I that I like the message I
really like stories with messages and
making people aware of certain things no
matter what like I'm I'm in a series I
worked a series regular role as The
Secret Life of the American teenager and
I play a 16 I'm actually 15 in pregnant
so yeah it's it's something that not
many people would approve of but it's
something that is a big problem here
it's common so I think it's great to
spread awareness you know even we so
typically you know ask the younger
actors you know what they learn from the
more experienced actors but a film like
this what have you learned from working
with Wayne and Sierra how simple it
could really be and I really mean that
is the true compliment it I think I have
a tendency to complicate things
maybe it's the actress in me that you
know the the you know the the actors
neither you know that can appreciate it
dramatic plots um but you know for
instance she has incredible access to
her emotions she's this this girl is
still incredibly talented and it's such
a pleasure to work with her and to watch
her access her emotions so easily it was
incredible to watch and I remember one
day we're trying to get there was this
emotional scene the scene on the bus and
you know my director really wanted me in
tears and I was like I don't know I'm
not feeling them maybe the character
doesn't want to cry you know you have
those kind of moments of like you know
so I started kind of like forcing
emotion out and that's never fun but um
but I did and I and I and I looked to
her and anytime you know the camera
would even be on me not even on her and
she would be crying her tears and be
flowing there was no effort though it
wasn't anything it just she allowed it
to happen I remember looking at her
remember I asked you that day I said
it's her first movie but I asked her how
do you do it when she says I just think
of what my character's going get it
together and so again the simplicity of
that just the simple kind of like going
back to the basics
it was great to just kind of go back
some actresses are conscious about this
age thing
yes a lot of veterans well when you get
these kind of roles where that you can't
be the the sexy one in the movie but
you're the mom what's your take on sex
he's just one component you know it's
something it's not a thing I am it's a
thing I can be it decided myself I can
tap into but just like I can tap into my
funny side or my quirky side reminder
that excited but it's not what I am so
and then just kind of rewinding a bit my
first role that put me on the map in
this business was in training day there
was only two scenes but that actually
that's what got me in that's what you
know that's what started it all and I
played a mother so I am actually really
you know I think that once you you know
when you play a mother just by the
nature whether you play a bad mother or
you know not-so-great mother or an
amazing mother being a mother already
has so much it's already so complicated
you know it's already three-dimensional
automatically no matter what the role is
because you're playing the mother so I I
welcome it and I am you know sorry the
arms the more complicated a role can be
the more flawed a character can be
that's what I'm looking for you know I
look for the Julia you know the careers
that I admire and would try to you know
and actually try to emulate in a way
it's those of Julia and more and that
Benny those women to me make amazing
choices and they're sexy beautiful women
but that's not you know that doesn't
dictate their choices sorry sorry
there's so many powerhouse latina
rolls in this and I mentioned that that
the other girl that was here but how do
you feel about this like coming together
of all these like powerful kind of
Latino women because there's real women
have curves that came out there's like a
better life which was sort of risky and
this is like really brave and bold so I
just wonder like do you see it well this
is movie but do you see that coming like
as a trend or how do you feel about it I
don't know all I can say is anytime I
see women out there all from all walks
of life from all you know ethnicities
when I see women actually having
something to do whether it's in
television or film that's exciting for
me you know that's that's what you know
I mean I wish I wish writing was a
talent that I had unfortunately I just I
tried I'm just not talented in the
writing department but if I was I would
just write complicated roles for women
because there's a lot of them out there
why that was an important trip for you
and also yes I went to see early on last
year about six months ago and it was
actually the based on this book called
half the sky that Nick Kristof wrote
with his wife Sheryl we're doing a PBS
documentary four-part series titled you
know with the same title called half the
sky and my portion is is the Sierra
Leone portion and I went to Sierra Leone
to meet this amazing local woman by the
name of Amy who started this
organization called the rainbow center
that helps girls that are victims of
rape because basically ten years ago the
civil war ended there so people have you
know no longer burn each other's
villages no longer shoot eat
shoot one another but the rates have
continued and especially a huge
percentage of these young women that are
raped are under 12 so we went there to
shed some light
and in October I believe changes do you
think that's really real that people
could change that quickly do those there
anything in your life that you can make
sure you're late to that the people can
change that quickly like I mean I think
that moments like you know I'm taking a
pic and he can change a lot so I yeah I
do believe that people can change
quickly but then you know but I do I
have I think that we have the ability to
change and because I think we're
habitual creatures and once we figure
out that bad habit whether it's
behavioural or whatever it may be once
we figure out and identify that we
change it you know and then we you know
we change our habits and you know
obviously I'm simplifying it and it
sounds very easy to do and we all know
it's very difficult but it's doable I
would never use it
reliability okay yes I am it's in a
state of transition but that's what I
love that's my little labor of love my
home my things I called Mita